COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WILL
NOW COME TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING
AND WELCOME TO HEARING OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IN
RESPONSE TO THE CALL THE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT ARE
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARING
HERE IN THE- STREET BUILDING AND
OBVIOUSLY I ASK FOR ALL MEMBERS
TO BE HERE. SO WE CAN ESTABLISH
A QUORUM TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING
ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT SUCH
PROFICIENCY REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WE WILL USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY REMOTELY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUAL WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR. I
WILL SAY THAT AGAIN EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR AND THE ACCESS CODE IS FIVE
TWO FIVE FIVE ONE SEVEN THREE.
FIVE TWO FIVE FIVE ONE SEVEN
THREE. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
AND OR COMMITTEE WEBSITES. WHEN
WE MOVED TO OUR PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO.
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THERE
MAY BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE. FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTED AND YOU WILL BE READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST
DELETE THAT EXCUSE ME. MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND SO WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE REMEMBER WHEN YOU START
TO TALK. MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING OR HEARING THIS
PROCEEDING ON THAT WILL HELP.
OBVIOUSLY I MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTION MUTED.
IT'S ALSO A GOOD TIME TO REMIND
EVERYBODY THAT IF WE DO HAVE ANY
TESTIMONY. THAT THIS IS A FISCAL
COMMITTEE SO PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO THE PHYSICAL
ASPECTS OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON PLEASE REFER-
REFRAIN FROM REPEATING. AND
LITIGATING YOUR PRIOR POLICY
COMMITTEE TESTIMONY. WE HAVE
THIRTY THREE BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. AND ALL OF THE MEASURES
ARE SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
INFORMED US THAT THEY DO NOT
HAVE FILES FOR ANY OF THE BILLS
WE ARE HEARING. AND THE
REPRESENTATIVE WILL NOT BE
PARTICIPATING TODAY. BEFORE WE
TAKE TESTIMONY ON THE BILLS I'M
GOING TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
PORTANTINO I AM HERE PORTANTINO
HERE SENATOR BATES. CENTER
BRADFORD. SENATOR JONES-
KAMLAGER YEAH SIR KAMLAGER HERE
SENATOR LAYERED HERE LAYERED
HERE CENTER BY CAL SKI YEAH MY
COUNTY HERE FOUR MEMBERS
PRESENT. WE HAVE A QUORUM- SO
NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
THE BUSINESS OBVIOUSLY DO THE
CONSTRAINTS AND THE LACK OF
HEARING TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATION
CLEANING PROTOCOLS. I WILL BE
INSTITUTING A TIME LIMIT ON
TOTAL WITNESS TESTIMONY- SO ALL-
PRIMARY WITNESSES. COLLECTIVELY
WILL BE GIVEN A TOTAL OF FIVE
MINUTES TOTAL TIME. AND OTHERS
WISHING TO TEST TOMORROW TESTIFY
MUST LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURE.
COMMONLY CALLED ME TOO. IF
NECESSARY WILL LIMIT THAT
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY TO TEN
MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE I DON'T
THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE- NEEDED
TODAY. BUT I'LL BE WATCHING THE
TIME AS WE PROGRESS AS REMINDER
ALL WITNESSES SHOULD LIMIT THEIR
TESTIMONY TO THE PHYSICAL
ASPECTS OF THE BILL. AND REFRAIN
FROM- RELITIGATE THE POLICY
MERITS. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
OUR FIRST BILL WHICH IS SB EIGHT
THREE THREE BY SENATOR DODD ON
COMMUNITY ENERGY RESILIENCE
ACTIVE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO-
IT IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION SO
WE'LL MOVE RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY FOR ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT SURE ANYONE
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT THREE THREE. SEEING NO
RUSH TO THE MICROPHONE WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE PUBLIC ON OUR
TELECONFERENCE- WRIST MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP THOSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. EIGHT THREE THREE NOW IS
THE TIME. I WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT THREE
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON
ZERO AT THIS TIME. YES MA'AM WE
HAVE A COUPLE QUEUEING UP. SORRY.
OKAY WHEN THEY'RE IN YES OKAY
YOU BOTTOM LINE. THEY JUST
DISCONNECT I APOLOGIZE HERE. ALL
RIGHT ANYONE ELSE. THEN SUPPORT. OKAY AND WE DO HAVE ONE MORE
JUST MOMENT. ONE SIXTEEN. BY
SIXTEEN AT HELLO MY NAME IS
MARGARET FERGUSON I'M FROM ZIP
CODE AREA NINE ONE SIX ONE SIX
IN SENATOR DOTS DISTRICTS I'M A
MEMBER OF YELLOW INDIVISIBLE AND
AT THE STATE INDIVISIBLE CLIMATE
JUSTICE WORKING GROUP AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL I
THANK SENATOR DODD FOR BRINGING
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE AND
FOR LETTING ME COMMENT. THANK
YOU. HERE WE HAVE NO NOT AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WE HAVE TAKEN THE
SUPPORT POSITIONS THAT WILL GO
TO OPPOSITION AND THERE'S NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM. WISHING TO OPPOSE
SB EIGHT THREE THREE MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO OPPOSE SB EIGHT THREE
THREE. IF YOU WISH TO POST THIS
THE FIRST ONE IN THERE AT THIS
TIME. YES MA'AM WE HAVE- ONE
CHEWING UP.
OKAY IN ORDER Y. NUMBER NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SANTIAGO WITH
CALIFORNIAN BY MENTAL VOTERS WHO
ACTUALLY SUPPORT OF THE BILL. IN
THE SHARE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THE TIME ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE TAKEN BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITIES FOR SB
EIGHT THREE THREE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I SEE NO HANDS GOING UP
TO WITHOUT OBJECTION SB EIGHT
THREE THREE WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO OUR SECOND BILL. WHICH IS. SB
EIGHT THREE NINE BY SENATOR DODD
ON ELECTRICITY DEMAND RESPONSE
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION SO
WE'LL MOVE RIGHT TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHT THREE NINE SEE
NO ONE IN THIS ROOM MODERATOR
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE ON SB
EIGHT THREE NINE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT THREE NINE.
ORDER S. B. THREE NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND YOUR AT THIS TIME. IT'S JUST WHAT WE DO HAVE ONE
COMING UP. ONE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING A
LARGE PARTY BECAUSE IT'S BETTER
CALIFORNIA EDISON IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. MISTER TERRY
OF NO ONE ELSE CLEAN UP AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT THREE
NINE THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO SP EIGHT. THREE NINE. OCSP
EIGHT THREE NINE THREE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. HERE WE HAVE
NO ENTRY UP AT THIS ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT THREE
NINE SEEING NO HANDS FROM MY
COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ON SB EIGHT
THREE NINE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
EIGHT THREE NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SENATOR
DODDS SB EIGHT FOUR SIX ON
ALCOHOL BEVERAGES RETAIL ONSITE
LICENSING OFFICIELLE PRIVILEGES
TO SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO
RIGHT TO SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
FOUR SIX THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM. COMING TO THE MICROPHONE
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT FOUR SIX. SUPPORT SB EIGHT
FORTY SIX EACH PRESS ONE TO
VERIFY. IN THE FUTURE WE HAVE
KNOWN CANNABIS TIME ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF SB
EIGHT FOUR SIX THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSE BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
SB EIGHT FOU SIX. SB EIGHT FOUR
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND YOUR AT
THIS TIME. SURE WE HAVE NO
INSURANCE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
HAVE BEEN TAKING SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITIES. THREE
FOUR SIX AND SEEING NO HANDS OF
MY COLLEAGUES GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB EIGHT FOUR SIX WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON SB
EIGHT FIVE SIX BY SENATOR DODD
ON WILD PIGS- THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAVED.
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AND WE WILL GO
RIGHT TO THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT FIVE SIX. SEEING NO RUSH
TO THE MICROPHONE WE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINE SB EIGHT FIVE SIX
ANYONE WISHING TO SUPPORT SB
EIGHT FIVE SIX MODERATOR NOW'S
THIRD OPPORTUNITY. THE SUPPORT
SB. THE PROJECT THE FIRST ONE IN
EUROPE THIS TIME. MR HAVE KNOWN
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
WE WILL GO TO OPPOSITION OF
EIGHT FIVE SIX SIGNAL ON IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
EIGHT FIVE SIX. IF WHICH OPPOSE
SB FIVE SIXTY FRANCE ONE AND
ZERO. YOU HAVE ONE TWO YUP JUST
MOMENTS. ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CARE
NUMBERS JASON BRYAT ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION WESTERN UNITED DAIRY
OF BOTH GROUPS HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON THE
BILL- TO ADDRESS SPECIFIC ISSUES
WITH REGARDS TO I TEN TAKE A
FERAL PIGS AS WELL AS PROVISIONS
AND HUNTING PRESERVES WITH A
FOUR TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
AS A BILL THE SWORD. THANK YOU.
AND YET HERE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. ALL RIGHTS HAVE BEEN TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION ENCINO HANDS
MY COLLEAGUES GO UP. THE I'M
SORRY MR BY COUNTY. I HAVE A
QUESTION BECAUSE THE CURRENT
TECH PROGRAM. HAS A COST WITH
THE FISH AND WILDLIFE AND WE GOT
THE COST ON THE VALIDATION
PROGRAM. AS SIX MILLION OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS WAS THERE WAS THE
DELTA IT IS THAT THAT STUDENT.
IS THAT ADDITIONAL COSTS OR IS
THAT JUST THE STANDALONE COSTA
FROM TO IN THE- THE- THE
VALIDATION PROGRAM. BECAUSE THE
TECH PROGRAM COSTA SOMETHING
THEY GOT ATTACKED THOSE. SIX
KEEP RECORDS OF FROM SO THAT'S
JUST THAT WAS JUST ONE THE
QUESTIONS THAT I THAT I HAD I
REALIZE THAT THERE'S SOME LOST
REVENUES FROM ON THE LICENSING
SIDE- BUT- JUST. WHEN I READ IT
I WAS THAT WASN'T CLEAR TO ME ON
REPORT. BOTH GENTLEMEN ARE
READING IT. WITH. SIX ARE GOING
ON SUSPENSE MAYBE WHAT WE COULD
DO IS GET BACK TO US ON THAT
BEFORE WE'LL GET TAKE FINAL
ACTION. THAT'S A GOOD IDEA.
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB EIGHT FIVE
SIX WILL GO TO SUSPECTS. MOVING
ON TO SENATOR DODDS EIGHT SIX
FIVE. IT IS ON JUNIOR HUNTING
LICENCES AGE OF ELIGIBILITY IT'S
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION. OF A RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED MODERATES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHT SIX FIVE. IF YOU SUPPORT
THIS ISSUE PLEASE PRESS ONE WHEN
THEY ARE AT THIS TIME. IF YES
MA'AM WE DO HAVE ONE COMING UP.
OVER ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHICH IS YOUR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BILL
GAINES SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE SPONSORS OF THIS
LEGISLATION THE ROCKY MOUNTAIN
ELK FOUNDATION THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER. FOUNDATION THE
CALIFORNIA DEER ASSOCIATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSEMAN FOR
CONSIDERATION PLEASE TO STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE WE
THANK SENATOR DODD FOR THROWING
THIS OFFICE. COMPORT LEGISLATION
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE. WHY
NUMBER ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THAT YOU'RE A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD AND
READ WITH NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION ALSO IF YOU'RE FOR
GUN OWNERS TO CALIFORNIA TODAY
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE
HAVE NO L. SECURE AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOT OPPOSITION
OF EIGHT SIX FIVE THERE'S NO ONE
AROUND TWELVE HUNDRED MODERATES
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO S. B. EIGHT SIX FIVE.
THANK YOU A POST SB. SIX FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND YOUR AT
THIS TIME. WE SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
TUNING UP AT THIS ALL RIGHT
HAVEN'T TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OPPORTUNITIES AND SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
EIGHT SIX FIVE. WITH ASSISTANCE
MOVING ONTO SENATOR DODD'S FINAL
BILL ON TRANSPORTATION
RESILIENCY IT'S S. B. TEN FORTY
NINE IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION AND
WE WILL GO RIGHT TO TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY AROUND
TWELVE HUNDRED. LOTTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN FORTY NINE.
WHICH SPEAKING SUPPORT OF SB TEN
FORTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
YOUR AT THIS TIME. SURE WE DO
HAVE SOME ACUTE UP JUST A MOMENT.
OKAY AND WILL. ONE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS KIM CHANG WITH THE AUTO
CLUB OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
WE SUPPORT THE BILL. SURE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
SB TEN FORTY NINE. THE PUSH
OPPOSE SB TEN FORTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. YES WE HAVE NO
ONE TO NOT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
MR WHITE HOUSE HE HAS A QUESTION
ON TEN FORTY NINE THAT JUST A
COMMENT MISTER CHAIR THE STAFF
REPORT L. QUICKLY POINTS OUT
THAT THE THEY DON'T MAKE A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN HOW MUCH
MONEY IN THIS TRANSPORTATION
RESILIENCY PROGRAM WOULD GO
TOWARDS. THE HIGHWAY PROGRAM ON
RESILIENCY OR THE OTHER PROGRAMS
AND AS THE BUDGET CHAIR ON THOSE
THINGS THAT WOULD BE. I WOULD
FAVOR AN OPEN ENDED ON THE WHAT
WERE THE AMOUNTS WE GO FOR CREEK
RATHER THAN A FIXED AMOUNT THAT
HAS TO GO TO HIGHWAYS THANKS.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE MISTER WHITE
HOUSE IS COMMON NO OTHER HANDS
IT'S GONE UP SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TEN FORTY NINE.
VOTE TO SUSPEND THOSE ARE MISTER
DODD FILLS THE MOVE ON THE
SENATOR AMBERG SB EIGHT THREE
SEVEN ON DRIVER'S LICENSE FROM
THAT VETERANS DESIGNATION
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE CENTERS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT
TO SUPPORT. THERE'S NO ONE IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED AND SUPPORT
MODERATES FOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT. OF SB
EIGHT THREE SEVEN. WISH IF YOU
TO SPEAK WITH. SB EIGHT SEVEN
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MR HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT THREE
SEVEN THERE'S NO ONE AROUND
TWELVE HUNDRED MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE. OPPOSE
STATE. THREE SEVEN. I THINK
YOU'RE SUPPOSED PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND YOUR AT THIS TIME. MR HAVE
NO INJURY AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
HAVE A TAKE IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION IS SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP SB EIGHT THREE SEVEN WILL GO
TO SIX SUSPENSE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. MOVING ON TO SENATOR
LEYRITZ BILLS SB EIGHT FIVE OH
ON SPECIAL DEATH BENEFITS
ADDITIONAL PERCENTAGES CHILDREN
OF MEMBERS. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CATTLE CANDIDATE MY COLLEAGUE IS
WAIVED HIS PRESENTATION SO WE'LL
GO RIGHT TO SUPPORT. ANYBODY IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT FIVE OH THERE'S
NOBODY IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT FIFTY. PUSHES SUPPORT SB
FIVE ZERO PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. SURE WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'LL
GO TO OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED OPPOSED
EIGHT FIFTY IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB EIGHT
FIFTY. IF YOU WISH ABOVE THE
SPEED FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MMHM.
YOU KNOW ONE THING UP AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT SENATOR LETTER
JUST A BRIEF COMMENT BECAUSE
NORMALLY THE SOMETIME SO
RIGHTEOUS BILL GOES ON CONSENT
TO NOBODY EVER TALKS ABOUT IT
BUT THERE HAVE BEEN TWO LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND A
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTER KILLED
IN THE LINE OF DUTY IN THE LAST
EIGHT YEARS THAT WERE NOT
LEGALLY MARRIED TO THEIR SPOUSES
EACH OF THESE THREE HAD TWO KIDS
AND EACH. OF THE SETS OF TWO
KIDS. GETS MUCH LESS IN
SURVIVORS BENEFITS JUST BECAUSE
THEIR PARENTS WERE NOT MARRIED
AT THE TIME THE PERSON WAS
KILLED IN THE LINE OF DUTY. THIS
BILL FIXES THAT SITUATION AND I
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE HARD DOING
IT RETROACTIVELY BUT IT LOOKS
LIKE PURSES GONNA COME ON AND
SUPPORT AND SO. IT'S A MINUSCULE
EXPENDITURE BUT I THOUGHT IT WAS
JUST FAIR TO CALL EVERYBODY'S
ATTENTION SO THEY KNOW THIS HAS
GONE ON AND THEY KNOW THERE'S A
BILL TO FIX IT SO THANK YOU FOR.
ALLOWING ME TO COMMENT I KNOW
THIS IS GOING TO THE SUSPENSE
FOR. ABSOLUTELY AND IT'S A VERY
LAUDABLE. PROPOSAL ON. FIXING A
PROBLEM. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB EIGHT FIFTY. WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE SP EIGHT EIGHTY.
ON WATER DIVERSION. IS OUR NEXT
MOVES IS OUR NEXT BILL SENATOR
LAYERED AS WELL- WILL GO WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
EIGHTY. HE WISHES FOR SB EIGHT
EIGHTY PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE CAN. OF COURSE
WHAT WE DO HAVE ONE COMING UP.
THIS IS FIXED. HE. I WILL GO TO
ONE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING SENATORS THE MORNING
SENATORS AND MEMBERS NO WELL
KRAMER'S WITH WINDS JONES
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SB. EIGHT
SURE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE AND
DECIDE ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT EIGHTY
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB EIGHT
EIGHTY. IN PUSH OPPOSE SB EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD OUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND YOUR AT THIS TIME. I'M
SURE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE COMING
UP AT THE TIME. ALL RIGHT WITH
TICKETS FOR IN OPPOSITION OF SB
EIGHT EIGHTY SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB EIGHT
EIGHTY WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. WE
WILL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT. AUTHOR
PORTANTINO. SB EIGHT FIVE ONE ON
CAL GRANTS FOR. INDEPENDENT
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER LEARNING.
I HAVE WAY PRESENTATION WE WILL
GO RIGHT TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT FIVE ONE THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT FIVE ONE. IF YOU WISH TO
SUPPORT SB EIGHT FIVE ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND YOUR AT THIS TIME. SURE WE HAVE KNOWN YUP AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT FIVE ONE
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED MODERATES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED EIGHT
FIVE ONE. IF YOU WISH OPPOSE SB
EIGHT FIVE ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND YOUR AT THIS TIME. SURE WE
HAVE KNOWN. UP OUR I SEE NO
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AND NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
EIGHT FIVE ONE WITHOUT A
SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB TEN
SIXTEEN PORTANTINO SPECIAL
EDUCATION. ELIGIBILITY FOR FETAL
ALCOHOL SPECTRUM DISORDER. I
WILL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT
IN SUPPORT THERE IS NOBODY IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN SIXTEEN. IF
YOU WERE SUPPORT SB TEN SIXTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND YOUR AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO INSURANCE
SHARE ALL RIGHT TO THE LEAD TO
THE OPPOSITION- THERE'S NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO TEN
SIXTEEN. ANYONE OPPOSE WE CAN
FIFTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
YOUR AT THIS TIME. HERE WE HAVE
KNOWING QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION SEEING NO QUESTIONS
OKAY NO NO SEE NO QUESTIONS ON
TEN SIXTEEN WITHOUT OBJECTION
THAT BILL WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
GOING ON THERE SB. THIRTEEN OH
TWO PORTANTINO SPECIAL EDUCATION
- ELIGIBILITY. I'M NOT BROWN
ONCE USED- ON PEOPLE HEALTH OR
WELLNESS CENTERS- I'VE WAY
PRESENTATION THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN OH TWO.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTEEN OH TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE KNOWING SHE UP AND AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO S. B. THIRTEEN OF TWO. IF YOU
WISH SIX NOMINATIONS ONE ZERO.
SURE WE HAVE NO INCREASE. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION SEEING NO HANDS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THIRTEEN OH
TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ON TO SENATOR HUESO SB EIGHT
FIVE SEVEN NINE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS UNIVERSAL
SERVICE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION I WILL
OPEN THE PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE UP- SUPPORTING SP. EIGHT
FIVE SEVEN. WHICH SUPPORT SB
EIGHT FIVE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. SURE
WE HAVE KNOWN CHEWING UP AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT FIVE
SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED. MODERATOR'S
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
SB EIGHT FIVE SEVEN. HE WAS
SUPPOSE SB FIVE SEVEN PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. SURE WE HAVE
NO ONE TO. HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND SEEING NO HANDS
OF MY COLLEAGUES GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION EIGHT FIVE SEVEN WE'LL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN BY SENATOR
EGGMAN ON CALIFORNIANS OF VICTIM
COMPENSATION BOARD MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED IN SUPPORT.
OF SB EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN MODERATE
SURE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. HE WAS SPEAKING SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN THREE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO INTENTION OF TIME
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
OF EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSE STATE SEVEN SEVEN.
YOU SHOULD NOT LISTEN TO THAT
SPEECH SEVEN ONE PRESS ONE AND
YOUR AT THIS TIME. HERE WE HAVE
KNOWN CHEWING UP AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND SIGNAL HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO SENATOR HERTZBERG
SB NINE OH THREE ON PRISONS
CALIFORNIA REHABILITATION
OVERSIGHT FOR. SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION SO GO RIGHT TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED. HERE TO
SUPPORT SB NINE OH THREE
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE OH
THREE. HE WISHED NINE OH THREE
B. PRESS ONE THE DURING THIS
TIME. SURE WE HAVE NO ENTRY UP
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION OF SB NINE OH
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
SB NINE OH THREE. WHO'S SPEAKING
ABSOLUTION OF S.
WE HAVE NO INJURY UPDATES. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND SING UP WITH THAT
YOU KEEP RAISING YOUR HAND
MISTER WHITE CASKEY KEEP MESSING
ME UP. SEEING NO OTHER HANDS
OTHER THAN MR WHITE HOUSE KEYS
ARENT HAND- WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
NINE OH THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON SB NINE
FIFTEEN BY SENATOR MAN ON FIRE
ARMS ON STATE PROPERTY THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE CENTERS
WAY PRESENTATION. AND SO- RIGHT
TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE FIFTEEN. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK ON. A SUPPORT SB NINE
FIFTEEN THE FIRST ONE AND EUROPE
THIS TIME. I HAVE NO INJURY AT
THIS TIME PLEASE TRY WITHOUT
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE FIFTEEN
SEE NO ONE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED WILL GO BACK TO THE
PHONE LINE IS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE. OPPOSED TO SP NINE
FIFTEEN. IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
NINE FIFTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JUST A MOMENT. OKAY LET'S
GO TO ONE ELEVEN THE BILL HAS.
THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD DANRY
WITH NASA RIFLE ASSOCIATION ALSO
IF YOU'RE FOR GUN OWNERS TO
CALIFORNIA'S PROPOSITION THANK
YOU. IN THIS YEAR WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN TO ASSIST. ALL RIGHT
HAVE A TAKE IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION TO THE SP NINE
FIFTEEN AND SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB NINE
FIFTEEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. THE
SENATOR LEYVA ON SEXUAL ASSAULT
VICTIMS RIGHTS THIS IS A SUSPEND
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION. OF THE RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED IN SUPPORT
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SIXTEEN. THE PUSH SUPPORT SB
NINE SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO MEETING FOR THE FACT ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF
SB NINE SIXTEEN IS NOBODY IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
OPPOSED SB NINE SIXTEEN. ENGLISH
OF HOUSES NINE FIFTEEN THE FETCH. ONE ZERO FIVE. I HAVE NO
INJURY AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT I
WOULD TAKE IT SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF SB NINE SIXTEEN AND SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
NINE SIXTEEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
SENATOR DORADO HAS THREE BILLS
WILL GO ON TO THE FIRST ONE SB
NINE FIFTY NINE FIFTY ONE AND
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE- THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION. OF A RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE FIFTY ONE MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIFTY ONE.
SPEAKING SUPPORT OF SB NINE
FIFTY ONE PRESS ONE AND YOUR AT
THIS TIME. AND JUST WHEN WE HAVE
A COUPLE SHOOTING UP. OKAY WE'LL
START WITH ONE TWELVE WHICH
WOULD. KATIE WATER SMITH WITH
THE CALIFORNIA WORKING FAMILIES
COALITION WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF SB NINE FIFTY ONE
THANK YOU. AND WE'RE GONNA MIND
TWENTY FIVE. MORNING SHARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS A
G. LOOK AT THAT ON BEHALF OF
UNITED WAY AT COST PLUS
SPONSORED BILL I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF. FIFTY NINE FIVE ONE.
IN THE FUTURE IF NO ONE ELSE
WOULD YOU AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION OF
SB NINE FIFTY ONE THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED OPPOSED
TO NINE FIFTY ONE MODERATORS FOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO NINE FIFTY ONE. IF YOU WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE NINE TWO ONE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THE TIME.
OKAY NO ONE SHOWING UP THE TIME
TO SHARE ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
FIFTY ONE AND WE HAVE NO HANDS
GOING UP SO WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
NINE FIFTY ONE WILL GO TO.
SUSPEND LIVING ON S. B. TEN
FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR DORADO-
STATE OF EMERGENCY OR EMERGENCY
CONDITIONS FOR EMPLOYERS RICK
RETALIATION ISSUES- THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAVE PRESENTATION. WILL GO RIGHT
TO PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE HUNDRED MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN FORTY FOUR. HE
WAS SPEAKING ACCORDING TO BE TEN
FORTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN THIS YEAR
WE HAVE NO ONE TO NOTHING. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED OPPOSED TO TEN FORTY
FOUR MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE. OPPOSED SB. TEN
FORTY FOUR. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF- SB TEN FORTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND YOUR
AT THIS TIME. AND JUST WHEN WE
HAVE A COUPLE OF.
OKAY M. START ONE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
PETER WATER WITH BIKE AT THE
VALLEY INDUSTRY AND COMMERCE
ASSOCIATION AND WE OPPOSE. TEN
FORTY FOUR. JUST NUMBER ONE
NUMBER EIGHT HE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I NEVER. EIGHTEEN AND THEY
DROPPED IT YOU. SUBCLASS ONE BIT
NO NOTHING TO AT THIS TIME YES
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN FORTY FOUR
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TEN FORTY FOUR WILL
GO TO SUSPEND SPENDING ON THE
TEN FIFTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
DORADO DISABILITY INSURANCE THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION SO
WE'LL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED IN SUPPORT. OF SB TEN
FIFTY EIGHT MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINEIN SUPPORT OF S.
B. TEN FIFTY EIGHT. IN SUPPORT
OF SB TEN FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND YOUR AT THIS TIME. IT LOOKS LIKE WE'LL START WITH
MY NUMBER TWELVE. KATIE WATER
SMITH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
WORKING FAMILIES COALITION AND
WE ARE A STRONG SUPPORT SB TEN
FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU. OKAY WE
HAVE ONE MORE TO SMALL. OKAY
NUMBER ONE THIRTY THREE GO AHEAD
. HI KATIE WIDGET FOR LEGAL AID
AT WORK IN SUPPORT AT TEN FIFTY
EIGHT AND OFTEN NINETY ONE IF
IT'S NOT TOO LATE THANK YOU. THE
MESSAGE CARE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL NOT OPPOSITION OF SB TEN
FIFTY EIGHT THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE MIGHT
OPPOSED SB TEN FIFTY EIGHT.
WE'RE SUPPOSED SB TEN FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. HERE HAVE NO
INJURIES AT THE TIME. ALL RIGHT
OF TEN FIFTY EIGHT. WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TEN FIFTY
EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
SERVING ON THE SENATOR ARCHULETA
ON S. B. NINE FIFTY FOUR. ON
PUBLIC WORKS- THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AND THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENTED SUPPORT SEVENTY
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIFTY FOUR.
IF YOU WISH FOR SB NINE FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MISTER CAREY OF
KNOWING QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
OF SB NINE FIFTY FOUR. THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM COMING TO
THE MICROPHONE TO SUPPORT SHOULD
BE OPPOSE NINE FIFTY FOUR
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED B NINE FIFTY FOUR.
THANK YOU WISH I'LL JUST BE NINE
FIFTY FOUR THE FIRST ONE THEN
ZERO THIS TIME. MR HAVE NO ONE
TO AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB
NINE FIFTY FOUR. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
THAT OBJECTION SB NINE FIFTY
FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVIE
ON SB ONE OF ONE THOUSAND SIX BY
SENATOR JONES ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT. HOMELESS OUTREACH
TEAMS THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAVE
PRESENTATION. OF ALL RIGHT TO
TESTIMONY SUPPORTERS NOBODY ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE. IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE THOUSAND
SIX. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE THOUSAND SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. SURE HAVE NO ONE KING
UP AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'LL
GO TO A POSITION OF ONE THOUSAND
SIX. IS THERE ANYONE IN THIS
ROOM KNOWS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO SP ONE
THOUSAND SIX. THE PROPOSAL SB
ONE THOUSAND SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN DIRECTORS TIME. JERRY
HAVE NO INJURY AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF ONE THOUSAND SIX
AND NO HANDS ARE GOING UP SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ONE
THOUSAND SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON S. B. TEN
TWELVE BY SENATOR GLAZERS. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATES ON
STATE PARKS OPEN FIRES- THERE
HE'S WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO
RIGHT TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
TWELVE IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
TWELVE. SPEAKING SUPPORT OF SB
TEN TWELVE WE PRESS. ONE ZERO
FIVE. WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME IS FOR ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF SB TEN
TWELVE THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
SB. TEN TWELVE. SB TEN TWELVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN YOUR AT
THIS TIME. THE MYSTERY OF NO ONE
KEEPING UP THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OPPORTUNITIES AND SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TEN TWELVE WILL GO TO SUSPEND.
WE WILL MOVE ON TO PRO TEM
ATKINS HAS TWO BILLS. BEFORE US
THE FIRST ONE IS S. B. TEN
TWENTY SEVEN ON TH SAN DIEGO
RIVER CONSERVANCY TO SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE PRO TEMAS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
TWENTY SEVEN. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
TWENTY SEVEN THE FIRST ONE THAT
ZERO THIS TIME. MISTER TERRY
HAVE KNOWN INTO AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION OF
TEN TWENTY SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED MODERATES
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
OPPOSED TO TEN TWENTY SEVEN.
SPEAKING OF POLLUTION OF SB TEN
TWENTY SEVEN THE FIRST ONE IN
EUROPE THIS TIME. MISTER JERRY
HAVE KNOWN KING OF. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
AND SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT HOPE MISTER Y. CASKEY UP
END UP FOR REAL FOR A HAND THAT
FOR REAL ALL. WHICH I JUST WANNA
MAKE A COMMENT ON THIS BILL TO
EXPAND THE SAN DIEGO RIVER
CONSERVANCY MY COLLEAGUE MISCON
LOCKER HAS WANT. SIGNIFICANTLY
EXPANDED BALDWIN HILLS
CONSERVANCY IN MISTER ALLEN
LATER WE'LL HAVE WANT TO EXPAND
THE SAN GABRIEL AND LOWER. LOS
ANGELES CONSERVANCY'S. HI FROM
THE FISCAL POINT OF VIEW I DON'T
KNOW HOW WE DIVIDE THE MUCH HOW
WE'RE GONNA BE DIVIDING THE
MONEY UP TO CLOSE THE
CONSERVANCY'S AND HOW THEY WILL
PRIORITIZE THAT. THE AT THE
DESIRE OF DOING MORE ON.
PROPERTIES OUTSIDE THE
CONSERVANCY BOUNDARIES RIGHT NOW
SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING EXACT IT
MOVES BUT WE HAVEN'T DONE AT
BUDGET SUB TO AN ANALYSIS OF ALL
THIS BECAUSE RESPONDING OF MONEY
FOR. VARIOUS CONSERVANCY IS
ANOTHER GROWING IN SIZE SO I
JUST DON'T HAVE A GOOD HANDLE ON
THAT. BUT I AM SURE YOU WILL AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME WELL IT'S-
THE OUT. OF MY COLLEAGUES GIVE
ME WORK TO DO. A GOOD THING. YOU
DON'T GET THE BILL BY THE HOUR
FIVE. ALL RIGHT- THAT IS ARE
COMMON AND WITHOUT OBJECTION S.
B. TEN TWENTY SEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ONTO SB ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN BY PRO TEM ATKINS
ON WORKERS COMPENSATION
LIABILITY PRESUMPTIONS TO
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE PRO TEMAS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED SUPPORT. MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE HUNDRED
. SB. ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN. IF
YOU SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. SURE
WE HAVE NO NEED TO AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT OPPOSITION OF
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN. IF YOU WERE
SUPPOSED SB ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
PRESS ONE AND YOUR AT THIS TIME. MYSTERIUM KNOWING KING UP THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT AND SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN WE GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO SENATOR
NEWMAN HAS S. B. TEN. THIRTY SIX
ON CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE-
AND HE HAS WAY PRESENTATION AND
WE WILL GO RIGHT TO TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN THIRTY SIX.
WHICH IS ALSO ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA OCEAN COURT PROGRAM-
SING KNOWN IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED WILL GO TO- THE PHONE
LINE IS OR ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF
TEN THIRTY SIX. WHICH IS SUPPORT
SB TEN THIRTY SIX THE FIRST ONE
THEN ZERO THIS TIME. MISTER
TERRY OF NO INSURANCE THIS TIME
RIGHT WITHOUT OPPOSITION OF TEN
THIRTY SIX YEARS NOBODY IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO TEN THIRTY SIX. SPEAKING
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. SURE HAVE KNOWN TO
HAVE BEEN TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND SEEING NO HANDS
FOR MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TEN THIRTY SIX
WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR KAMLAGER HAS TWO BILLS
STARTING WITH SB FIFTY TEN FIFTY
TWO ON THE BALDWIN HILLS
CONSERVANCY- MADE FAMOUS BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE HE'S
COMMENTS. WE WILL NOW GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT- SHE'S
WAY PRESENTATION WE GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT AND THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT
OF SB TEN FIFTY TWO MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN FIFTY TWO.
YOUR SUPPORT SB TEN FIFTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND YOUR AT
THIS TIME. JUST A MOMENT WE DO
HAVE ONE KING.
OKAY WELL SORRY ONE NUMBER TEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS OMAR HERNANDEZ I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF POLICY IN
PARTNERSHIP OF THE SOUTH LOS
ANGELES TRANSIT EMPOWERMENT ZONE
FOR SLEEP. AND CALMLY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB TEN FIFTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MISTER
TERRY OF NO ONE ELSE COMPUTE
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN FIFTY TWO
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED MODERATES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB TEN
FIFTY TWO. SUPPOSED TO BE TEN
FIFTY TWO PRESS ONE AND YOUR AT
THIS TIME.THANKS JERRY OF
KNOWING KING OF THE SITE. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. MISCON LONGER. I
WASN'T PLANNING TO SAY ANYTHING
BUT SINCE EVERYONE ACOSTA
BROUGHT MY BILL UP I DO WANT TO
SAY SINCE HE SAID IT WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPAND THE BOTTOM
CONSERVANCY WHICH IT WOULD IT
WOULD STILL BE SIGNIFICANTLY
SMALLER THAN ALL OTHER
CONSERVANCIES IN THE STATE SO I
DON'T WANT ANYONE TO COME IN FOR
THE SIGNIFICANT THAT WORD
SIGNIFICANT THAT HE USED TO BE
QUITE COST. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TEN FIFTY TWO WILL
GO TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY. MOVING
TO S. B. THREE THIRTEEN OH FOUR
BY SENATOR COM LONGER ON PRISON
RELEASE ALLOWING THIS IS A
SUSPECT CANDIDATE. AND THE
SENATORS WAVE PRESENTATION WILL
GO RIGHT TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. THIRTEEN OH FOUR
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED MODERATE IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE. IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. THIRTEEN OH FOUR. GIVE
SPEAK SUPPORT OF S. THIRTY OH
FOUR. PRESS ONE AND YOUR OF THIS. MR HAVE NO INSURANCE WE WILL
GO TO OPPOSITION NOW AND THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB THIRTEEN OH FOUR. YOU
WERE SUPPOSED SB THIRTEEN OH
FOUR THE FIRST ONE AND YOUR AT
THIS TIME. WE SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
ACUTE THIS TIME ALL RIGHT HAVE A
TAKE IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
AND SEEING NO HANDS OF MY
COLLEAGUES GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THIRTEEN OH FOUR
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. SB TEN
SEVENTY SEVEN BY VICE CHAIR
BATES THIS IS ON THE COASTAL
RESOURCES CLIMATE READY PROGRAM
GRANTS. IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION SO WE WILL GO RIGHT
TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. TEN SEVEN SEVEN THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
SEVEN SEVEN. CORDOBA'S BE TEN
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO INTERNET ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF TEN SEVENTY SEVEN
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED MODERATES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO TEN
SEVEN SEVEN. HE WAS SPEAKING
OPPOSITION OF THIS AND SEVEN
SEVEN PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE
HAVE NO ONE TO GO THANKS FOR
HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
ENCINO HANDS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TEN
SEVEN SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO SENATOR ALLEN HAS
TO BILLS FIRST ONE IS S. B. TEN
SEVENTY EIGHT ON SEA LEVEL RISE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION AND
WE'LL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT
IN SUPPORT. OF ANY ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED MODERATES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TEN SEVEN EIGHT. BUSH IN SUPPORT
THIS TEN SEVENTY THE FIRST ONE
THAT THERE AT THE TIME. WE HAVE
NO INJURY AT THIS TIME SHARE ALL
RIGHT WELL GOOD OPPOSITION OF SB
TEN SEVEN EIGHT THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED OPPOSED
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB TEN SEVEN EIGHT
- JUST BE TEN SEVENTY EIGHT. THE
FIRST ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
INTERNET AT THE TIME ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION AND SEEING
NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB TEN SEVENTY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON THE S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO BY SENATOR
ALLEN ON THE SAME GABRIEL AND
LOWER. LOS ANGELES RIVER AND
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY WHICH HAS
ALREADY BEEN COMMENTED UPON- THE
AUTHORS WAVE PRESENTATION AND WE
WILL MOVE RIGHT TO PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED SUPPORT
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO. WHICH SB ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
YOUR AT THIS TIME. THIS YEAR WE
HAVE NO ENTRY UP AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN TWENTY TWO.
MODERATORS FOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE WITH A TO ME THERE'S NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY
TWO. WHICH SPEAKS IN SB ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. SHARE HAVE KNOWN
AND THROUGH THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
WE WILL O TO OPPOSITION OF
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM ANYBODY OPPOSED. TO
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO.
SURE WITH PHONE. IF YOU WERE
SUPPOSED TO SB ELEVEN TWENTY TWO
THAT'S ONE ZERO. WE HAVE NO
INJURY AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN TWENTY TWO
AND SINGLE HANDS OR QUESTIONS OF
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB ELEVEN TWENTY TWO WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. DR PAN HAS S. B.
TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN ON CLINICAL
LABORATORIES HE IS WAY
PRESENTATION AND WE WILL GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMON IN
SUPPORT. THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED WISHING TO
SUPPORT SB TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
SIXTY SEVEN. YOUR SUPPORT SB
TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. SURE WE HAVE
NO ONE IN TRUTH ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE
SIXTY SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED OPPOSED TO
TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN. MODDERS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
SB TWELVE SIX SEVEN. NUMBER IF
YOU SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWELVE SIX SEVEN PRESS ONE IN
THERE AT THIS TIME. NO NEED TO
AT THE TIME ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF S.
B. TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN AND SEEING
NO HANDS WITH MY COLLEAGUES GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWELVE
SIXTY SEVEN. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPEND. OUR FINAL BILL IS BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ ON CALIFORNIA
TECH WITTY INNOVATION PROGRAM.
IS IF IT IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION SO
WE'LL GO RIGHT TO TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE THIRTEEN
TWENTY FIVE. THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY FIVE. SURE SPEAK ON S. B.
O. THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE PRESS
ONE AND YOUR AT THIS TIME. SHARE
HAVE KNOWING HE WITH THE TIME.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION OF S. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY FIVE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED. MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO THIRTEEN TWENTY
FIVE. SB THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE
THE FIRST ONE THE YEAR AT THIS
TIME. HEY WE HAVE NOTING TO
DECIDE ALL RIGHT SEEING NO HANDS
OF MY COLLEAGUES GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
FIVE. GO TO SUSPENSE THAT IS ALL
OF OUR BILLS ON THE FILE.
ALL RIGHT- WE'VE CONCLUDED OUR
AGENDA BUT I'M GOING TO KEEP THE
COMMITTEE ROLLING FOR THE NEXT
TEN MINUTES TO ALLOW SOME
MEMBERS TO COME BACK. I'LL MAKE
BY PARTING COMMENTS NOW BUT I
WILL DOUBLE DOWN- YOU GUYS CAN
OKAY. THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS HO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC COMMENT IF YOU ARE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL RECORD SO- PLEASE.
COMMUNICATE AND WILL INCLUDE YOU
AND FOR THOSE WHO GOT THROUGH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
AND WE'RE GONNA STAY OPEN FOR A
COUPLE MORE MINUTES. THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE.
APPLE NOW. THERE YOU GO. ALL
RIGHT THIS STATE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HEARING
IS ADJOURNED. AT.